in an hfl sport science European
supplement survey 114 products were
purchased from 24 top European nutrition
brands incredibly 10% contained
prohibited steroids or stimulants in
addition 44 percent of UK anti-doping
positive tests in 2012 macaws by
prohibited substances contained in
supplements risking it all athletes rely
on sports nutrition products but some
are putting their reputations and their
health on the line by using product
ranges that haven't been tested for
banned substances at sis is UK
Innovation Centre their market leading
three pronged informed sport testing
regime is minimising any risk of
contamination and promoting clean sport
some of the world's best athletes use
our products and we're simply not
willing to have the possibility that
some of our products are unknowingly
contaminated this is incredibly
important to us because athletes
reputations and careers are on the line
so we've invested heavily in processes
and procedures to minimize the risk of
banned substance contamination in our
products and in our factory processes
and we were the first brand to be
awarded the Evolve certification for
inform sport for minimizing that risk
we're also only one of two brands to
have a full product range registered and
tested
it's truly market leading it's
comprehensive not all products are
accredited in the same way nothing is
left to chance and this factor has
enabled sis to become innovators within
the sports nutrition market sis have
their own in-house lab to ensure
standards are kept high not only on the
factory floor but through suppliers as
well so when we are making your products
we take every step to ensure that we're
working in a banned substance free
environment this includes hand and body
hiding and a clean working environment
samples are taken and analyzed by the
lab at LGC who look after the informed
sport program a Quality Assurance plan
for sports nutrition products inform
sport comes to sis twice a year to
conduct an audit this audit is done
unannounced so that sis cannot be
prepared for it this is how confident
they are in their processes in terms of
minimizing the risks associated with
contamination inform sports also goes
out into the marketplace and purchases
products from sis we then test those put
them through our anti-doping screen just
to make sure that none of the finished
products have been contaminated and that
we are actually testing the products
which the athletes themselves are using
and I've used science to support
products for a number of years primarily
because I trust them you're getting dog
control tested after a race or randomly
any time you have to be confident that
the product recruiting in you have been
bashed tested and are 100% pure this is
the most robust risk analysis program
available and we're delighted sis has
gone beyond the standard testing and
takes its responsibility so seriously
you